et c'est donc son parti à la guerre on
va c'est notre équipement aux malades
casque on aller sur le terrain
entre des sifflets ronde avec un tas
d'autres ports dédiés qui a la
permission de frapper la malbaie ça fera
mal dans to put mettre de la glace dans
le foot choses seront ni ça viendra
jamais c'est une famille une tribu une
arme est presque une religion un sport
qui fait mal mais qui électrise des
milliers de garçons
ces jeunes gladiateurs sont prêts à tout
donner sur le terrain
encore cette année 1 sur 5 fera une
commotion cérébrale et les gens qui
devraient les protéger ne sont même pas
au courant
il
au collège notre dame de montréal
le football c'est cyril ses joueurs
n'ont que 15 ou 16 ans et sont encadrés
par onze entraîneurs alors que les
autres élèves sont encore en vacances
les gars du programme de football se
sont retirés à 150 km de montréal pour
vivre 100% football sert en convoi des
adolescents mettre autant par un projet
comme celui là
puis le fait qu'autant de plaisait je
pense que les jeunes en retire beaucoup
au niveau de l'éthique de travail au
niveau de julien qui peuvent se créer au
niveau de tout ce qui peut ressortir
d'un engagement comme celui là ici on
prend les commotions cérébrales au
sérieux autant que le football donc on
parlait de 2 comment s'en passer
la plus récente est un printemps de
maintenance avant le début de la saison
tous les joueurs sont soumis à une série
de tests qui mesure les capacités de
leur cerveau ça nous donne mère mary des
deux malfrats qui est autant nouveau
cognitif que équilibre que mémoire que
cinq confus
60 euro ralentit 2 après une commotion
on refera le même test et le jeune
reviendra au jeu seulement si les
capacités de son cerveau sont revenus à
leur niveau de base au camp
d'entraînement on apprend à bloquer à
claques et de la façon la plus
sécuritaire possible mais ça compte
quand même
avant même le début des matches
deux joueurs des cactus auront subi des
commotions cérébrales
nous avons décidé de suivre toute la
saison des quatre russes du collège
notre dame
nous installons dans les casques de
certains joueurs des censeurs fait par
les compagnies chaque box et ryder
cette technologie mesure la force des
coups reçus à la tête et transmet
l'information instantanément aux
thérapeutes sportifs dans le vestiaire
une nouvelle recrue françois rochon
c'est beaucoup plus intense que que
n'importe quel autre sport que j'ai fait
c'est très spécial
françois est un joueur de soccer ce soir
il va jouer son premier match de
football
est ce qu'on peut
[Musique]
sur les lignes de côté notre dame à deux
thérapeutes sportifs qualifiés qui sont
à l'affût des blessures et des
commotions pourtant pendant la partie
lot 5 censeurs détecte si un pacte à la
tête dont quatre sur le même joueur d
impact important que personne n'avait
fait un saut à la demi seconde à faire
c'est pour les autos sont tous ceux qui
avaient eu une époque où les octos cru
on n'y a pas une petite évaluation
rapide pour voir où aucune commotion à
signaler dans le premier match
la surprise la soirée c'est françois
rocheleau le nouveau il a un talent
exceptionnel
merci
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
deuxième match au deuxième quart
françois rocheleau a déjà fait deux
touchés moi je pourrais avec le bas
quand j'ai le ballon je me suis fait
plaquer
puis en tombant un autre joueur est venu
et m'a donné un coup de casque en
arrière de la tête reçoit ne se relève
pas j'ai vraiment senti comme un flash
direct dans ma tête au moment du coup
puis après ça j'étais tout étourdi
puis je te pas capable de me concentrer
sur quoi que ce soit à notre dame
le protocole est clair dès qu'un joueur
a des symptômes de commotion le
thérapeute le retire du jeu pour le
reste du match
et si le physio ne t'avais pas interdit
de retourner ce que tu serais retourné
si ça dépendait de moi même je serais
retourné françois sera hors jeu pour au
moins deux semaines
le protocole de gestion des commotions
n'est pas à la fine pointe dans toutes
les écoles
je pensais qu'une commission serait pas
c'est un job je pensais que ce n'était
pas grave le ster c'est une blessure
comme une fleur de pouce de jérémy gouin
gosselin le numéro 56 joue pour une
école de l'estrie en 2012 sur ce jeu
dans la première demie du match il faut
une commotion cérébrale
je savais j'ai fait une commotion mais
je voulais pas sortir parce que j'étais
dessus
jérémy fini le match malgré des
symptômes importants
je joue ma madeleine de but de ma vie
mais j'ai eu dix neuf plaqués deux sacs
me rappelle un peu la première de nîmes
la deuxième dame il rappelle toi il n'ya
pas de thérapeute sportif sur les lignes
de côté personne ne remarque que jérémy
a des symptômes de commotion sauf sa
mère à la fin du match pendant un mandat
local
pourquoi parce que je parle d'être
lendemain pu trouver des choses normales
deux semaines après sa commotion jérémy
revient au jeu sans que personne ne
s'assurent qu'il est guéri laisse que
les soigneurs les coaches sont fait
faire des tests pour voir c'était
correct
pas vraiment c'était plus des questions
le buzz commence notre démo tête ici à
toi finalement à ton jugement à tes
réponses
tu leur mentait lutter cinq mois plus
tard quand jérémy abouti dans le bureau
de la neuropsychologue julie bolduc
teasdale
il a encore des maux de tête quotidien
en 2010 où tu avais eu un épisode de mon
père après chaque pratique de football
100 et 120 cannelle partageant ensemble
ils découvrent que la commotion que
jérémy était probablement sa 5e et qu'il
a souvent joué alors que son cerveau
n'était pas guérie
ce qui aurait pu lui être fatale dans
certains cas nos ddc souhaite à deux
commotions cérébrales qui ont été subies
le nageur des lettres au co sans
nécessairement parler de décès on peut
avoir la deuxième commotion
ça peut être une blessure qui est
beaucoup plus complexe donc des
symptômes plus intense qu'ils prennent
plus de temps à guérir
dans certains cas il peut même y avoir
des séquelles au niveau langage la
motricité
c'est ce qui est arrivé à kevin croise
ni un joueur de l'université bishop's à
lennoxville en 2011 qu'elle venait
retourner au jeu pendant un match au
cours duquel il avait subi une commotion
un deuxième impact à la tête a provoqué
une deuxième commotion
kaven a perdu l'usagé de la parole et il
est paralysé du côté droit
j'ai l'impression de l'avoir échappé
belle ouais ouais j'avais pu j'aurais pu
avoir des pubs plus pire
qu'est-ce que j'ai eu et j'ai été
chanceux
le cas de jérémy est loin d'être
exceptionnel le neuropsychologue des
vallées morgue vient de publier un livre
dans lequel il parle d'épidémie
silencieuse pour moyens danger puis pile
est grave parce que on ne réagit pas
adéquatement aux commotions cérébrales
d'une part on les identifie pas tout
repose sur le jeune qui va aller dire à
son coach et coach me sens pas bien je
pense que j'ai eu une commotion
cérébrale
plusieurs experts affirment que 80% des
commotions cérébrales ne sont pas
diagnostiqués on est facilement des en
retard au québec et aussi au canada sur
la gestion des commotions cérébrales et
ça fait en sorte qu'on a des jeunes qui
mais qui risquent leur vie en jouant
dans nos sports
on se rappelait la taille et la
destruction des tours jumelles aux états
unis au collège notre dame
l'aumônier fait partie de l'équipe c'est
l'entraîneur spirituel fois que l'on
découvre ces cas l'homme capable de
poser des gestes héroïques à toi aussi
de poser des gestes héroïques comme
joueur dans ton match de ce soir
amen dans le vestiaire
un grand absent françois roche ou en
repos forcé à la suite de sa commotion
sur ordre du médecin
il ya aussi quelques demi journée à
l'école présente au jour des symptômes
mon coeur il se repose à la maison
c'est l'angelot rivard le numéro 34 qui
remplace françois rocheleau comme
porteur de ballon
vers le milieu du match il se fait
plaquer et reste au sol
lens ou daisy jeté par terre je savais
pas quoi faire
si j'attends de me chercher sarah hoblyn
m
[Applaudissements]
lancelot est légèrement sonné le
thérapeute le soumet une série de tests
qui ne révèle pas de symptômes de
commotion cérébrale
c'est correct le thérapeute permettre à
lancelot de retourner au jeu et lancelot
termine la partie
ce n'est pas ce qu aurait fait la
neuropsychologue julie bolduc this day
ça change tellement rapidement la
recherche maintenant se sont dit quand
le joueur est sonnée y pas de retour au
jeu la journée même
il a été sommé déjà là vous avez votre
part vous auriez même pas obligé par un
test pour le retirer du jeu souvent les
symptômes de commotion se présente
plusieurs heures après l'impact
c'est ce qui est arrivé à lens long
ah ah
au match suivant lancelot n'est pas en
uniforme
ces symptômes se sont déclarés le
lendemain du match samedi et dimanche
j'ai eu
matt est mal au ventre j'ai dormi
presque toute la fin de semaine
j'avais vraiment beaucoup d'énergie
est-ce que tu considères tu te fais une
erreur cette journée là dessus de la
misère avec ça
bien sûr bien sûr parce que ben en fait
c'est la ligne est toujours très fines
que si on marche au cette ligne chinois
c'est la quatrième commotion de la
saison pour les cactus le thérapeute
nicolas michaud est très compétent il a
une formation universitaire de 4,1 et
des milliers d'heures de pratique
si même lui peut faire des erreurs
imaginez les autres beaucoup de
soigneurs sont des bénévoles qui ont
suivi un simple cours de premiers soins
c'est le minimum requis par le règlement
de football québec sur les lignes de
côté la docteure linda landry en a vu de
toutes les couleurs
il ya un jeune que tu as été frappé à la
tête de façon importante notre jeune à
nous s'est relevé en tube halo john est
restée partage carlo james et relevé y
était du pied - il y avait les yeux dans
le vague était vraiment tout à l'envers
pia jouer le quart suivant fait que le
puits avait deux soignants à de l'autre
côté
ne s'improvise pas soigneurs qui veut
même si elle est médecin
la docteure landry a suivi une formation
de cinq jours sur les blessures
sportives avant de devenir soigneur dans
l'équipe de son fils jusqu'à touré fama
jetez pas bonne en commençant cérébrale
quelqu'un frais venu me voir je pense
que j'aurais pu le retourner au jeu trop
tôt parce que ça faisait pas partie de
mes intérêts parce que j'avais pas
nécessairement ceux dans ma clientèle
toutes les équipes n'ont pas la chance
d'avoir une docteure landry aujourd'hui
son équipe joue contre une équipe locale
de joliette
[Musique]
leurs soigneurs est une patrouilleuse de
ski mais elle n'est pas toujours là
lorsque l'équipe joue à l'extérieur
c'est parfois l'entraîneur lui même qui
fait le travail
vous avez vous déjà fait des formations
particulières pour les commotions
cérébrales non j'ai vu mes formations
non car on est dans l'incertitude
on va consulter le soigneur de l'équipe
adverse vous m'apprenez quelque chose
j'en reviens pas jean-charles méfaits
tombe des nues
il est pourtant directeur de football
québec l'organisme qui est responsable
de la sécurité des jeunes athlètes
ça n'a pas de sens alors la seule
explication que je peux voir soft une
explication budgétaire un pilote étire
l'élastique à un prix en dieu ça n'a
aucun sens que woods
le gouvernement a pourtant investi des
millions de dollars dans le sport
étudiant
en dix ans on est passé d'une centaine à
400 équipes de football dans les écoles
la plus grosse subvention que de fouet à
obtenir c'était pour le football a
acheté les cas c'est paul est tous à 50
60 me alors tout le monde a voulu cela
c'est la daille se sont effectivement
lancé dad
savez-vous la pression que ça nous offre
nous vend on a mis de l'argent sur les
épaulettes mais pas sur les soigneurs
des stages à vay forme des corvettes
forme des arbitres c'est un saut la
réalité quand je te dis on est rendu un
wagon n'est plus une combative
contrairement à ce qu'on pourrait penser
il y a plus de blessures à la tête
au niveau secondaire qu'au niveau
collégial et universitaire au collège
notre dame
on n'a pas attendu les directives de
football québec pour s'organiser
lorsqu'on écoles décide de créer un lien
de football faut qu'ils décident de le
faire comme il faut
alors il ya des avantages mais il ya
quand même des choses qu'il faut
s'assurer d'avoir pour protéger les
jeunes françois rocheleau n'a plus de
symptômes mais pour s'assurer que son
cerveau est guéri le thérapeute lui
faire passer le même test qu'en début de
saison
c'est un outil qui est bien développée
qui est développé un consensus mondial
donc quand même énormément de
professionnels qui développe ce genre
d'outil la pression à la peine
une étude québécoise a démontré que sans
ce genre de test de joueurs commotionné
sur trois sont retournés au jeu avant
que leur cerveau ne soient guéris
un outil précieux que très peu d'écoles
utilise parce que vous nous donnez le
test cognitif l'homme et son mât une
solution ne le connais pas mais a tué
mais c'est pas ça libe slam casque la
vitesse de fonctions cognitives de base
j'en entends parler mais c'est pas mon
pain et mon beurre ni mon quotidien
l'eau c'est clair
nous avons fait des demandes d'accès à
l'information dans trente écoles qui ont
des programmes de football
selon la documentation reçue c'est sur
30 seulement nous ont semblé gérer les
commotions de façon prudente dans ce
tableau que nous avons confectionné on
voit que les meilleures écoles ont un
nombre de commotions élevé parce qu'elle
les détecte bien dans les écoles plus
négligente les commotions semble passée
quasi inaperçue
françois a réussi son test cognitif
il peut donc commencer le protocole de
retour au jeu graduelle de six états si
tout va bien
dans une semaine il pourra jouer
5e match de la scène jean françois
rochon est de retour ça m'inquiète un
peu
parce que à chaque commotion on devient
plus fragile pour en avoir un autre donc
inquiétant la première commotion de
françois l'a rendue jusqu'à cinq fois
plus à risque d'en faire une deuxième
6e match pour la première fois de la
saison notre dame est sur le point de
perdre d'argent un jeu de galles sont ok
on va le voir je veux dans les dernières
minutes du match
l'équipe tente une longue passe à
françois rocheleau qui pourraient
égalisé le pointage
françois se fait plaquer violemment
voilà que ses pensées ses doigts je sais
pas moi
[Musique]
le thérapeute retire françois du match
il est inconsolable
je te poses pas une telle émotivité peut
être un signe de commotions son père
quitte les gradins pour le rejoindre sur
le bar pas vraiment pas parce que alors
chez 15 ans il faut pourtant accumulé
comme une douzaine de soldats seulement
1,6 avoir des problèmes à long terme
5e commotion de la saison chez les
cactus pour françois rocheleau tout le
protocole est à recommencer
le football est dur pour le corps de
tous les sports c'est celui qui affiche
le taux de blessures le plus élevé chez
des adolescents à mesure que la saison
avance de plus en plus de joueurs
tombent au combat
soyez solidaires on a besoin d'un solide
pour les peupliers fait pas aujourd'hui
le dégoût profond qui prend la relève
le prochain vont devoir prendre la
relève
les cactus sont privés de françois
rocheleau pour affronter leur rival
historique le collège jean eudes
sur les lignes de côté françois ronge
son frein
ils fuient nos caméras ça va juste
débarqué de jeu pour cela mais je pense
à malou nous a achevés au coude pour
l'heure parce que le protocole est
tellement serré c'est ce et qui trouve
dur
ce sera un match épique la partie dure
quatre heures et se décide en
prolongation les censeurs que nous avons
installé dans les casques de cinq
joueurs enregistre 22 un pacte solide
il n'y a aucune commotion ce qui ne veut
pas dire que les coups reçus n'ont pas
causé de blessures
[Applaudissements]
alors oui j'aime ça car j'ai toujours
aimé faire des coups à la tête
l'ancien joueur des alouettes étienne
boulay on a reçu pendant 18 ans il a
déjà affronté les cactus il a commencé
sa carrière en secondaire 1 au collège
jean eudes faisant 88 livres et je me
serais quatre pièces dont la documenter
je n'ai pas au cas où je continue à
jouer
étienne boulay a fait sa première
commotion cérébrale diagnostiqués en
2011 avec les alouettes et moi j'arrive
avec mes verges de là et je le faisais
elle frappe de plein fouet
en comptant tous les trois sur le côté
d'une commotion cérébrale mais je prends
un bon parce que ben on est dans un
match serré je veux jouer parce que
j'écoute jouer parce que c'est ce qu'on
expose fr le maraudeur québécois doit
oublier le foot bal en 2011 toujours aux
prises avec des symptômes de commotion
cérébrale
pendant sa convalescence de plusieurs
mois étienne boulay découvre que sa
commotion actuelle n'est pas la première
blessure de son cerveau parce que je
comprends c'est que c'est à chaque fois
soit un trauma crânien et que tu aimais
les que ce soit quelques secondes
quelques minutes quelques heures on s'en
fiche c'est qu'ils étaient peut-être la
vue embrouillée tu as mal à la tête
c'est ça et ça pendant ma carrière j'ai
du personnel fois ça c'est évident il y
a les commotions
mais il ya aussi les sous commotion des
chocs qui ne sont pas assez importants
pour provoquer une commotion mais qui
s'accumulent et fragilise ne servent le
24 juillet 2011 le cerveau d'étienne
boulay n'était plus capable d'emprunt
ses coups à répétition la même s'ils ne
cause pas de commotion cérébrale bon
allez user le cerveau bon allez user
cerveau sur le plan chimique sur le plan
métabolique est aussi modifier son
fonctionnement dans un laboratoire de
l'université de boston
une équipe de chercheurs a étudié le
cerveau d'environ 150 athlètes décédés
dans la plupart des cas ils ont
découvert des dommages visibles à l'oeil
nu
c'est lié au traumatisme crânien
répétition comme sur crash
le docteur robert quand tous participent
à cette recherche
ce que nous voyons c'est le résultat des
dizaines de milliers de sucre motion
encaissés par ces athlètes qui
pratiquaient des sports de contact
jacques coup laisse des traces les
taches noires observée dans les cerveaux
sont des signes d'encéphalopathie
traumatique chronique une maladie qui
entraîne des troubles permanents de
mémoire d'humeur et de comportement
presque tous les cerveaux de joueurs de
football analysés étaient atteints
[Musique]
et ce qui inquiète c'est qu'on a trouvé
les fameuses taches dans le cerveau de
joueurs de football de niveau secondaire
nous avons dans notre banque
les cerveaux de six adolescents décédés
accidentellement leur cerveau ont été
examinés présentait des signes
d'encéphalopathie traumatique chronique
ces découvertes font dire à robert quand
tous que le football n'est pas un sport
pour les enfants
je ne laisserai pas mon petit fils
rouges balle avant l'âge de 14 wagons
cet âge le cerveau est plus léger et
donc plus facile à se courir en
proportion les jeunes d'une plus grosse
tête mentez sur un tout petit coup alors
même plus petit un pack arrive à secouer
violemment leur petit cerveau
au québec on commence à jouer au
football dès l'âge de 8 ans aujourd'hui
c'est la finale du championnat
provincial des 8-9 ans
[Applaudissements]
sinon ce n'est qu'au docteur robert
cantu des matches comme celui ci sur est
interdite mais voulait faire duction du
foot par kodak la boîte 14 ans qu'est ce
que vous en pensez
[Musique]
maintenant je suis encore là sinon nous
risquons encore 300 très heureux d'être
là on empêche les enfants de jouer dans
la rue on les empêchera pas de jouer au
foot balleurs à 14 heures se laisse pas
qu'ils ont choisi ça m'inquiète
énormément mais vous le laisser jouer
quand même parce qu'il ya le jeu
[Musique]
ça comme du
et votre rigueur numéro 4 dans leur
guerre depuis tantôt le pied ça doit pas
12 12 coups forts qu'ils allaient ça
vous inquiète pas non parce que je pense
qu'il tombe bien puisque ce relevé
[Musique]
le numéro 4 va finir le match sur les
lignes de côté blessé au dos nous avons
montré ces images à dave ellemberg ces
jeunes de 8,9 à la je les vois un clinic
et parents viennent me consulter
parce que leurs petits mais ils vivent
avec des mots tête déjà à l'âge de 8 9
ans des motifs en sorte qu'ils ont du
mal à se concentrer à l'école et tout
cela mais il retourne car même sur le
terrain
le directeur de football québec ne
semble pas inquiet au contraire
pour le moment les enfants de moins de
12 ans joue au football dans les ligues
civils seulement mais football québec
veut introduire le football dans les
écoles primaires demande nous là il faut
comprendre que notre fédération n'est
pas un ordre professionnel on n'est pas
là pour défendre l'intérêt du public
fédération vous pouvez pas dire non le
football aux primaires non bah ouais on
peut dire n'ont qu'à la rocqué élections
votants on va mettre celui qui dit oui
c'est ça notre structure aux malades
[Musique]
c'est l'avant dernier match de la saison
régulière pour le collège notre dame
[Applaudissements]
malgré le retour de françois rocheleau
les capteurs essuie une défaite
[Musique]
où
dernier match de la saison régulière
au début de la partie le numéro 62
frédéric comme nous gay reçoit un coup à
la tête
ils terminent le match malgré la douleur
qui s'installe absolument quand même ça
arrive souvent dans les parties de foot
on le sent les coups donc ça te ment à
la tête c'est normal mais c'est surtout
après quatre ans comcast est moins
normal
[Applaudissements]
pas facile de convaincre des joueurs de
foot bal de sortir du jeu pour un mal de
tête
est-ce que hier de plusieurs parmi vous
vous levez la main qui ont des mots
taille quand tu y joues qui ont déjà
joué avec des maux de tête à la fin du
match quand l'adrénaline retombe
les symptômes de frédéric comme nous gay
s'amplifie migraine étourdissements
nausées
c'est la sixième commotion de la saison
pour les cactus les séries éliminatoires
commencent la semaine prochaine
le plus dur est à venir
[Musique]
cette année les cactus ont des chances
de remporter le championnat provincial
le prestigieux paul d'or
pendant les trois semaines des séries
éliminatoires les joueurs se donnent à
fond dont les pratiques avec contact on
n'a pas le choix d'en faire un petit peu
si on veux pas les mettre en danger
la journée du match les jeunes doivent
s'habituer à jouer avec contact en
pratique pour pouvoir performer meurent
aujourd'hui de nouvelles commotion
surviennent durant les pratiques ce qui
porte le nombre total depuis le début de
la saison à lui il y a vraiment beaucoup
plus de blessures à la tête au niveau
réservataires secondaire et même chez
les tout petits
si on compare avec la ligue nationale de
football caf cher parce que chez les
professionnels il ya maintenant un
règlement qui limite les pratiques avec
contact à moins d'une par semaine
dans les écoles il n'y a pas de limites
imposées les écoles font ce qu'elles
veulent à notre dame
ces deux fois par semaine nous on doit
leur enseigner ces choses on doit
enseigner la base on peut pas présumer
que ces jeunes l'ofppt pratiquer comme
desjardins fr
[Musique]
la saison n'est pas encore terminée et
les quatre sont déjà huit commotion dont
la moitié en pratique rien
d'exceptionnel
l'autre équipe sur le terrain dans ce
match de demi finale on est à 12
commotion
[Musique]
le collège jean eudes grand rival de
notre dame a aussi atteint un total de
douze commotion un joueur sur quatre
[Musique]
dans un de leurs matches un joueur de
l'équipe adverse a dû quitter le terrain
en ambulance
il en était à sa deuxième commotion en
trois semaines si vous disait le cul à
8,10 commotion cérébrale par équipes
sportives par année est ce que vous
seriez surpris oui je serais surpris si
je la rue c'est le cas dans les équipes
qu'on a suivi entre 5 et 10 commotion
cérébrale dans une équipe
danilo 6 janvier poche tombe ce qu en
janvier pas qu'on nous dit pas ce que
que nos morts selon le règlement de
sécurité de football québec
les entraîneurs doivent envoyer un
rapport et qu'il y à la fédération
chaque fois que survient une commotion
cérébrale mais il ne le faut pas les
gens vous avons informé qui vous fait
peur c'est à dire on est deux dans cette
fédération si on est inondé de cheval
prendre pied en bois
on
[Musique]
il est étonnant de constater un tel
laisser aller quand on connaît les
conséquences potentielles des commotions
cérébrales
lorsqu'on a eu trois commotions nos
probabilités d'avoir des maladies au
niveau du cerveau dégénérative un peu
comme la maladie d'alzheimer augmente
par un facteur de 10 10 fois plus de
chances d'avoir la maladie d'alzheimer
de dépression majeure aussi après trois
commotions cérébrales
c'est d'en faire le plus de la partie
jérémy gouin gosselin a fait cinq
commotions
il est toujours un suivi avec la
neuropsychologue julie bolduc teasdale
pour évaluer les dommages qu'elles ont
causés si je pourrai reprendre le jeu f1
de joie je le reprendrai le jeu prendra
le temps guérit comme faux puis je
préfère jouer encore au football
aujourd'hui
le football c'est fini jérémy s'initier
au basket ball mais il n'est pas certain
qu'il pourra jouer des matches
la bonne nouvelle tout de même c'est que
depuis qu'il a cessé le football s'en
servent au fonctionnement
l'année passée il en va de ma commotion
jeu 53 mathématiques pour le premier
elle par l'état ristani le jeu penche et
70 mathématiques un brouillard et à
certains joueurs ont moins de chance que
jérémy la famille de keven quoi sni a
déposé une poursuite de 7 millions et
demi de dollars contre l'université
bishop qu'elle accuse d'avoir mal géré
ses commotions
vous n'avez pas pas d'avoir des
poursuites parce que au niveau universel
avec le dossier que vous me présentez
l'autre comme moi c'est kevin chief
parce que de toute évidence on fait pour
notre travail c'est ça
17 novembre 2013 à saguenay
c'est la grande finale les cactus vont
affronter le blizzard de québec
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
le père de françois rocheleau énervé ce
qui concerne google france c'est
excessivement compétition et vous tu vas
chercher la verge de plus pu s'y voit le
train d'exception ayant tendance à se
blesser soula sont prêts à se défoncer
[Musique]
les censeurs que nous avons installé
dans les casques de cinq joueurs ont
enregistré 84 impact important pendant
le match de la saison ce sont des
impacts importants
on sait que un impact d'environ 80 90 g
et qui vaut une collision à 60
kilomètres heure dans un mur là les
joueurs équipés de senseurs n'ont pas
fait commotion certains cerveaux sont
moins fragiles que d'autres
des études effectuées avec des censeurs
ont démontré que les joueurs de niveau
secondaire reçoivent environ sept cents
coups à la tête dans une saison si on
inclut les pratiques
c'est beaucoup trop selon les experts on
étudie maintenant le nombre d'impacts
encaissés par les joueurs et on espère
qu'avec le temps on réussir à définir
une limite raisonnable de coûts qu'un
joueur peut recevoir au cours d'une
semaine un mois ou une saison une année
saison
[Musique]
dernière minute du match les cactus sont
sur le point de remporter une victoire
écrasante
[Applaudissements]
il y a un prix à payer pour ce grand
bonheur en quelques saisons de football
les joueurs des cactus ont accumulé un
total de 21 une commotion cérébrale
ils ont eu la chance de jouer au sein
d'une école bien outillés ce qui est
loin d'être le cas de toutes les écoles
du québec
le temps d'un j'ai foi germain demain
trop tard pour certains c'était le
dernier match
mais pour françois rocheleau qui en
secondaire iv se fait déjà courtisé par
des équipes collégiales
ce n'est qu'un début plusieurs gars de
russie khl à guano anneaux c'est pour
cette saison là ça va passer l'an
prochain puis c'est un gars qui jouaient
plus loin et de jeu que les jeunes leur
staff
ces clouds
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
draps
[Applaudissements]